[Music]
well halftime show did you catch the old
Beyonce yeah Lord in heaven hot guy how
about the Beyonce she's got those a
giant legs yeah I mean she's got healthy
legs I mean I don't even think Paul
Bunyan has legs that big yeah she was
she was stomping around did you see her
stomping out like she just can't walk
normally she stomps everywhere like
there's ants on the ground I think
that's why the power went out she was
stomping so much like to see her in The
Hurt Locker trying to fuse a landmark
how long by the way Ghost Rider can you
tell I'm excited
who's Ghost Rider you call me Ghost
Rider well that's like a little nickname
oh okay
ghost ray you know that's cool it's fine
by me corn cob whatever you got no sack
of marshmallows you if you tell them all
jacked up I just got great news I just
got cast in the alien nein
[Music]
some guy apparently dropped out because
he couldn't understand French
voulez vous avec winner yeah now Harlan
we talk about everything whenever we're
on the show you were sad about any issue
how's your love life
oh sweet heavenly Terry turkey hockey
Wonder Bread women I'm finding are very
sensitive oh you're married yeah yeah
they're sensitive sometimes yeah and
women are very sensitive and what
there's one point in particular where
you got to watch what you say and it's
just before the lovemaking happens okay
and a woman starts taking off her
clothes yeah when she gets right down to
that last piece of fabric just as she
takes it off and she's standing there
nude do not say this oh hell no well
they get mad and the longer you drag out
the hell the matter they get like I did
one the other night was like oh hell no
yeah yeah but I'm gonna be in a leonine
so who cares I'm gonna get chicks left
right and center
good pretty cocky gun you do a lot of
looking around to the side that's what a
cocky guy does yeah well you know that's
what you do when you're half sea turtle
can I ask you about that I was checking
out the cover of your DVD here force of
nature and look at this for now why are
you a turtle why are you a turtle there
Harlan and it actually kind of worked it
works because I have no gym it really
works you know we just stuck as I shop
my special out in the middle of nature
and I thought it'd be a great cover to
have me as a tortoise you think that's
gonna that's gonna get the word out on
the DVD well why not yeah that could
work I love nature